à la réponse de Vladimir Poutine suite à
l'appel au soulèvement du patron de la
milice Wagner
Prigogine le président russe l'accuse de
trahison produit c'est un coup de
couteau dans le dos Vladimir Poutine
promet une réponse implacable on
l'écoute
et votre
action
et à nos camarades militaires qui
combattent actuellement sur le marché
qui se sont battus et ont donné leur vie
à la Russie à l'unité du monde russe
leur nom et leur gloire ont été trahis
par ceux qui ont tenté d'organiser cette
mutinerie ceux qui poussent le pays à
l'anarchie et au meurtre de nos frères
Russie à notre nation notre réponse à
une telle menace sera très dure
et pour commenter ses déclaration de
Vladimir Poutine nous retrouvons
elenaphologie notre ancienne
correspondante à Moscou spécialiste de
la Russie bonjour Elena pour commencer
quelle analyse faites-vous des
réponses de Vladimir Poutine à cette
situation aujourd'hui en Russie la prise
de parole du maître du Kremlin était
attendu
oui bonjour Philomé alors d'abord elle
était attendue elle est arrivée en
retard elle n'a duré que 5 minutes je
pense que Vladimir Poutine est en train
d'essayer de garder la situation en main
de garder le contrôle j'ai entendu ce
matin des analystes russes dire qu'il
est probablement déjà retranché quelque
part dans un bon cœur et à l'abri
il je pense que Vladimir Poutine à ce
stade est extrêmement inquiet évidemment
on le serait à moins
on a entendu hier il y avait gagné
Prigogine laisser en quelque sorte une
porte de sortie à Vladimir Poutine dans
cette toute première vidéo de 30 minutes
qu'il a publié et qui annonçait les
événements qui allaient venir et bien il
a surtout mis en cause le ministre de la
défense c'est un Game showgu pour avoir
menti au peuple russe sur les causes
véritables de ce qui est appelé en
Russie une opération spéciale et de ce
que j'ai fini Prigogine appelle lui une
guerre et surtout il a dit cela a
commencé parce que le bien joué vous
voulez une étoile de plus et parce que
le clan des oligarques au pouvoir
voulait cette guerre par clan des
oligarques au pouvoir il entendait
clairement Vladimir Poutine et le
premier cercle qu'on appelle le cercle
Peter bourgeois des oligarques qui l'a
porté au pouvoir et qui sont un peu
aussi les dirigeants de l'ombre du pays
entendés par là que il met en cause
Vladimir Poutine mais pas jusqu'au bout
c'est-à-dire que la principale offensive
de yefghani pregojin elle se fait contre
Sergueï chougout et contre le chef
d'état-major Valérie guerracimobs ce
n'est absolument pas clair de il réclame
qu'on les lui livre qu'on ne comprend
pas ce qu'il va en faire si jamais cela
arrivait mais dans tous les cas ce qu'à
annoncé prix gaugine c'est qu'il
marchait sur Moscou qu'il comptait
renverser la
direction militaire du pays et à partir
de là il dit que la Russie va pouvoir
recommencer à fonctionner et donc qu'il
admet que Vladimir Poutine lui reste au
pouvoir avec cette préparation Vladimir
Poutine a clairement fait comprendre à
gagner Prigogine que non qu'il entendait
conserver
que Prigogine était un traître qu'il
était un terroriste qu'il a appelé les
hommes à ne pas le rejoindre les soldats
comme Prigogine a demandé à ce qu'il le
rejoint donc Vladimir Poutine entend
garder le statu quo maintenant on en est
encore aux aurores de ce qui est en
train de se passer cela peut évoluer
extrêmement rapidement dans les
prochaines heures peut-être en tout cas
pour le moment Vladimir Poutine a blessé
entendre à gagner Prigogine qu'il ne
profitait pas entre guillemets de cette
porte de sortie entre guillemets qui lui
était offerte d'où la prochaine question
Elena wolochine Vladimir Poutine dit
avoir donné l'ordre aux forces de
sécurité de faire le nécessaire pour
revenir à la normale qu'est-ce que cela
signifie à quoi est-ce qu'on peut
s'attendre
alors on peut s'attendre à deux
scénarios selon moi le premier c'est que
les forces de sécurité prêtes allégeance
et assez troupes et en cela il y aura
donc ensuite des négociations pour
savoir quel sera le statut de trilogie
puisque pour le moment en tout cas
Vladimir Poutine a dit que c'était un
terroriste aussi Vladimir Poutine a dit
que il y avait une menace mortelle
contre le pays contre le peuple russe
entendait là contre son régime donc le
régime de Vladimir Poutine clairement là
peut tomber
là il y a peut-être du coup trois
scénarios le premier scénario c'est que
Vladimir Poutine reste en place
il y a en quelque sorte la mise en place
d'une jante militaire avec Poutine qui
se maintient au pouvoir ce scénario là
selon moi et peu probable ensuite le
scénario d'une confrontation armée tout
simplement il peut il peut il peut y
avoir des des scènes de combat dans
Moscou très très vite puisque là puisque
l'armée s'est déployée déjà dans la
capitale russe et autour de la capitale
russe et donc il peut y avoir une
confrontation armée avec les hommes de
Wagner et le troisième scénario c'est
que Vladimir Poutine tout simplement ne
parvient pas à se maintenir au pouvoir
c'est encore un peu confus donc c'est
difficile de ce sont des pronostics
vraiment
à chaud
si on regarde le push de 91 c'est
quelque chose qui a duré trois jours si
on regarde ce qui s'est passé à Rostov
cette nuit ou très tôt le matin il y
avait gagné Prigogine est entré et le
commandement militaire local on le voit
en ce moment sur ces images le
vice-ministre de la Défense youzbek if
kurof et un autre général que j'ai cru
reconnaître sur ces images voilà il
était il est en train de parler à
Prigogine en ce moment même et bien ce
général il avait appelé auparavant à
maintenir allégeance à Vladimir Poutine
ils se sont rendus donc cela peut aller
aussi très vite
Elena très concrètement est-ce qu'on est
en train d'assister de la part de yep
Kenny privé à un coup d'état une
tentative en tout cas de coach aussi
tout ce que je viens de décrire oui tout
à fait Philomène c'est un en tout cas
c'est un coup d'État militaire cela
aussi incroyable que cela puisse
paraître lorsqu'on le dit je ne vois pas
comment l'appeler autrement merci
beaucoup Elena Volochine spécialiste de
la Russie pour France 24 ancienne
correspondante de la chaîne à Moscou
merci beaucoup